the views and opinions expressed on this
program
are those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of 8 news now
or next our media group we are asking
the court
to recognize the fact that president
trump
was victorious in this election tonight
on politics now
lawsuits on top of lawsuits and then
more lawsuits we break down the legal
maneuvers going on
in nevada after the election plus well
politics
has and will play no role whatsoever in
the consideration development or
approval of our therapeutics or vaccines
the secretary of health and human
services talks to us about a potential
covid19 vaccine and how it'll be
distributed
like i've always said we hire from the
human races all the good bad and
indifferent and faults and bugs and
warts in the wake of calls for change of
police departments the i-team digs into
what metro police have done
and where some changes still need to be
made
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler election day is now
two weeks behind us but some questions
are still up in the air about nevada
and lawsuits flying back and forth we're
going to talk about
i screwed that up i'm sorry that's
totally me
didn't update the script that threw me
off i'm sorry
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now
or next our media group we are asking
the court
to recognize the fact that president
trump
was victorious in this election tonight
on politics now
lawsuits on top of lawsuits and more
lawsuits we break down the legal
maneuvers going on in nevada after the
election
plus well politics has and will play
no role whatsoever in the consideration
development or approval of our
therapeutics or
vaccines the secretary of health and
human services talks to us about a
potential covet 19 vaccine and
how it'll be dished out like i've always
said we hire from the human races all
the good bad and indifferent and faults
and bugs and warts
in the wake of calls for change of
police departments the i-team digs into
what metro police have done
and where some changes still need to be
made
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler election day is now two
weeks behind us
however some questions are still up in
the air about nevada
now lawsuits are flying back and forth
and we're going to start with clark
county
certifying all the results except one
race and that is the race for clark
county commission district c
democrat ross miller leads republican
stavros anthony by just
10 votes that's the only race
in the entire uh election where
we have any concern related to the
outcome and it's because of the close
margin
it's a district with 218 precincts a
margin of 10
is very difficult that is clark county
registrar joe gloria he says out of more
than 150
000 votes in that race there were 139
discrepancies
discrepancies include the number of
check-ins at a voting site not being the
same total as ballots cast
issues with same-day registration
signatures or
someone who'd tried to vote twice that
was the only race with more
discrepancies than the vote total
clark county commissioners decided to
try and hold a special election in this
race
saying a recount would only just recount
the discrepancies
stavros anthony's campaign manager
agreed
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
we are asking the court to recognize the
fact
that president trump was victorious in
this election
tonight on politics now lawsuits on top
of lawsuits then more lawsuits
we break down the legal maneuvers going
on here in nevada after the election
plus well politics has and will play
no role whatsoever in the consideration
development or approval of our
therapeutics or vaccines
the secretary of health and human
services talks to us about a potential
covet-19 vaccine and how it'll be
distributed
like i've always said we hire from the
human races all the good bad and
indifferent and faults and bugs and
warts
in the wake of calls for change of
police departments our i-team digs into
what metro police have done
and where some changes still need to be
made
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us on politics now
i'm john langler
election day is now two weeks behind us
however some questions are still up in
the air about the elections here in
nevada
lawsuits are flying back and forth and
we're going to start with clark county
certifying the results
except for one race and that is the race
for clark county commission district c
democrat ross miller leads republican
stavros anthony by just
10 votes that's the only race
in the entire election where
we have any concern related to the
outcome and it's because of the close
margin
it's a district with 218 precincts a
margin of 10
is very difficult clark county registrar
joe gloria says out of more than 150 000
votes there were 139 discrepancies
discrepancies include the number of
check-ins at a voting site not being the
same as the total
ballots cast issues with a same-day
registration signature or
someone who just tried to vote twice
that was the only race with more
discrepancies than the vote total
clark county commissioners decided to
try and hold a special election in this
race
saying a recount would only recount the
discrepancies stavros anthony's campaign
manager agreed
we've been hearing from everybody across
the entire district
how could this happen you know we voted
for stavros now's your chance you have
to turn out
however democrat and former secretary of
state ross miller said on twitter in
several tweets
that he is positive he won the race he
tweeted several times in the past week
including this one here
saying that he is thankful for the
outpouring of support rest assured i
have won
this election and here at the top he had
worked alongside the county attorney
here in clark county for many years
he basically says that i know her legal
opinion is just wrong as part of the
legal machinations in all of this the
question is whether there will be a
special election for commission district
c and right now that is still very much
up in the air nevada republicans though
used that county commission report to
file a fifth
lawsuit against this election cycle once
again alleging widespread voter fraud
it joins a list of others filed despite
no evidence of widespread voter fraud
orkomana breaks down this latest legal
challenge
we are asking the court to recognize the
fact
that president trump was victorious in
this election
contesting the election results that's
the goal of the trump campaign's latest
lawsuit filed tuesday afternoon in
carson city district court but final
numbers show joe biden beat president
trump by nearly 35 thousand votes in
nevada the legal challenge largely
includes allegations we've heard before
including that more than 15 thousand
people voted both in nevada
and another state voters who are listed
as dead voted
and the signature verification machine
in clark county was not reliable this
all comes back to the unsubstantiated
claim that nevada's expanded mail-in
voting system resulted in irregularities
we had a lot of improper ballots being
mailed to people's homes and apartment
buildings
nevada and clark county have created
this crisis reckless
unsolicited mail-in voting
has created this crisis the nevada
secretary of state who by the way
is a republican has consistently said
there is no evidence of widespread voter
fraud clark county officials also
releasing a statement saying in part the
trump campaign is quote
parroting erroneous allegations made
bipartisans without firsthand knowledge
of the facts
it's important to note that most of the
other lawsuits and legal challenges
filed by the trump team
have been rejected by the courts there
was one case currently pending
in federal court reporting in las vegas
orco mana 8 news now
all right so there have been five
lawsuits from the trump campaign against
nevada and
here's the scorecard three have been
tossed out by a judge or dismissed
the trump one to was to stop nevada
electors from voting for
joe biden has a hearing next week
another federal case
is ongoing it involves jill stokey a
legally blind woman we profiled here on
eight news now she says
someone cast her ballots for her so far
the trump campaign has had
no success with their lawsuits in nevada
the two cases with
court dates scheduled have those
hearings after the state is set to
certify the election and the electors
cast their ballot
for joe biden more litigation now
republican congressional district 4
candidate jim marchant
congressional district 3 candidate dan
rodimer and republican state senate
district candidate april becker have all
filed lawsuits over the election
becker lost to senate state senate
majority leader nicole cannizzaro by 600
votes
marchand lost to incumbent congressman
stephen horsford by a wider margin
and rodimer lost to congresswoman susie
lee all three of their lawsuits are
similar
they ask for the entire election to be
thrown out citing issues with clark
county's signature machines
and other problems previously listed in
those trump campaign lawsuits we were
talking about
again those complaints were already
thrown out by a carson city judge
in a separate lawsuit one thing that has
happened quite a bit since election day
president donald trump tweeting about
nevada you've also probably seen those
tweets tagged with this is disputed by
official sources that posted by twitter
so that was one of the topics on capitol
hill this week it turns out
many democrats and republicans are in
rare agreement that social media
companies need new rules on how to
operate
they just don't agree on what those
rules should look like facebook and
twitter say they took unprecedented
steps this year to fight election
misinformation
do you believe that label goes far
enough
to prevent the tweets harms when the
tweet is still
visible and not accurate
i do because it's not just the surface
level label
it points to a collection of
news articles of information and
conversation there
are instances in which your platforms
are
taking a very distinctively partisan
approach
and not a neutral one both ceos admitted
their companies have mistakenly flagged
or blocked content or users
while lawmakers say more regulations are
needed they also worry about whether too
much government involvement
could just create more problems next
year on politics now reforming the
police force
how much progress has metro police made
on use of force policies and diversity
our i-team investigates also we speak
with the health and human services
secretary about a potential covet 19
vaccine
and how it'll be passed out to the
public this is 8 news now
welcome back to politics now
there is still no word on whether
governor steve sisolak will put new
covid 19 restrictions in place next week
health officials say the most recent
numbers though are very alarming
nevada is experiencing increases in
cases hospitalizations and
deaths the state biostatistician says
our 14 day positivity rate is the
highest
so far it's 15.4 percent and she says
this implies there are potentially a lot
more undiagnosed cases
while the state is limiting large
gatherings to 250 people or half
capacity
the southern nevada health district is
recommending camping groups at 50 people
snhd is not recommending that large
gathering plans be approved at this time
although gatherings of 250 or less will
not be submitting plans for review snhd
recommends
limiting of gatherings to 50 or less
and it looks like that will be the case
for the next couple of weeks
this week governor sysolak said he would
soon make an announcement on any steps
that have to be taken but
no exact date was provided there was
also news this week of a vaccine being
95 percent effective
the i-team's vanessa murphy spoke with
alex azar about it he is the health and
human services secretary for the federal
government and
the head of president trump's covet 19
task force
mr secretary thank you so much for
joining us um
first let's start with the vaccine how
will it be distributed
and when could nevada start seeing it so
the vaccine will be distributed using
the normal distribution system that we
use in this country to put hundreds of
millions of doses of
whether it's flu vaccine measles vaccine
other childhood vaccines out
every year going to use the tried and
true systems that work every year for
this vaccine
also we will be distributing the
moderna vaccine if it is approved
through one of america's great wholesale
distributors and it will go
directly to wherever the state's
governor tells us
he or she would like vaccine to go
whether that's at a
retail pharmacy at a hospital a nursing
home
community health center or otherwise the
pfizer vaccine
again the governors will tell us where
they would like it to go
but we'll give them direction and pfizer
will ship it directly to that site
where we will match up that vaccine with
the kits that we have put together with
the needles the syringes the personal
protective equipment
to enable that vaccination to occur
ballpark
date could you provide um and also
in a state of about 3 million like
nevada how much would we initially get
well in terms of timing it's going to
depend first the companies have to apply
for authorization
before the fda pfizer has said publicly
that they expect to file within the next
couple of days i would hope that
modernity would get their application in
soon also
at that point the fda will run its
rigorous process to review all of the
data
safety and efficacy information they'll
run a public advisory committee process
to consider that information with an
independent body
once fda has granted authorization to a
vaccine
our colleagues on operation warp speed
from uh the defense department have said
that they believe they could have it
shipped out and received
within 24 hours we have also said
that we will be distributing the vaccine
which of course will be
in limited supply initially on a per
capita basis
across the country so nevada will get
its proportional
amount of vaccine based on nevada's
population compared to other states
it's no secret governor sisilek and
president trump have
clashed what would you say to people who
think politics could affect this or
people who may not trust the trump
administration
or the vaccine in that it moved so fast
well politics has and will play no role
whatsoever
in the consideration development or
approval of our therapeutics or vaccines
there are over five separate steps in
independent checks in the process
whether it's an independent data and
safety monitoring board which has
reviewed this data
to enable the company to see it the
company's own independent ethical checks
to ensure that they want to submit an
application
the fda's publicly published guidance of
what standards they will hold it to
the public independent advisory
committee that will consider
the vaccine application and then finally
the fact that it will be fda's career
scientists
who will make the determination to
approve and authorize a vaccine
politics have no place in in this type
of public health of therapeutics and
vaccines
alex azar speaking with vanessa murphy
there for now groups like
health care workers and nursing home
residents could get the vaccine
in december dr anthony fauci from the
national institutes of health says every
day that american everyday americans
rather
can be vaccinated as soon as april next
on politics now policing the police
if there are bad cops out there i don't
want them standing next to me out there
in the community
how metro police's use of force policy
has changed and who investigates claims
against the department
also raising money for education the
hurdle passed by two ballot initiatives
that would raise taxes for our schools
coming up next